good morning Hank it's Tuesday I have
the flu and everything hurts and I am
miserable in the world is a smoking pile
of burnt garbage and today I would like
to try to cheer myself up by telling you
two love stories okay so back in January
of 2012 when my book The Fault in Our
Stars came out we went on tour for about
a month and one of our first stops was
this hotel ballroom outside of
Washington DC before that show a bunch
of nerdfighters met up to hang out two
of whom were Sarah and Lewis now they'd
never met each other before but they
really hit it off on this day and so
they exchanged contact information and
then eventually they began dating they
fell in love acquired a dog named scout
and a cat named boo and then decided to
get married and they accomplished all of
this while I was failing to write a new
book but then I did write a new book and
we announced that we were going on tour
and returning to Washington DC on a day
that just happened to be two days before
Lewis and Sarah's wedding and even
though it was of course a very busy time
for them they managed to make it to the
turtles all the way down tour where we
presented them with a KitchenAid mixer
and a bottle of champagne because you
know that's what you need in a new
marriage love a KitchenAid mixer and
something bubbly to celebrate with and
then they got married with lots of
nerdfighter friends in attendance the
weddings dress code was and I'm quoting
directly here comfortable but dressy
rainbow colors which means it was almost
certainly the greatest wedding ever and
also look at these nerdfighters look at
all of these wonderful people
celebrating joy and dwelve behold hope
and life and everything that is not
influenza
I just barked between takes so that's
how my day is going let's go on to the
second love story okay we're going back
to 2012 so that October I visited a
library in Cincinnati and a couple days
before the event a guy named Kenny
tweeted me to ask if he should skip his
business law class to come to my book
reading and I said no because you know
school is more important but he came
anyway and he happened to sit next to
someone named Amy they chatted before
and after the show exchange contact
information and then eventually fell in
love they got two dogs and three cats
and bought a house together and then a
couple days before our return to
Cincinnati for the turtles all the way
down to her Kenny wrote to me on reddit
he said I met my girlfriend five years
ago at your book signing in Cincinnati I
want to propose now but don't know how
any advice
congratulations Kenny and Amy here's a
couple pieces of unsolicited wedding
advice one nothing matters except
whether you have an open bar and two if
at all possible make your dress code
comfortable but dressy rainbow colors
now I know what the vast majority of you
are thinking why hasn't this ever
happened to me and fair enough but you
have to remember if you're lucky this
happens to you exactly once in your life
Hank we are surrounded by injustice and
we are also surrounded by microbes and
we must never become complacent in the
face of these Horrors which is my way of
saying remember to get your flu shot but
we are also surrounded by love romantic
love friend love family love as the poet
wrote over 2,000 years ago love conquers
all and so we shall yield to it thank
you to Amy and Kenny and Sarah and
Louise and everyone else who has shared
their love with us Hank I am going to
bed I will see you on Friday